what's up guys before we jump this
episode of one on one with the great the
American Gangster Trail sewn in I gotta
keep the house lights on it's a little
ad read for you I partner up with my
friends at Fantasy Guru that's right I'm
not making pics anymore it's clearly not
going well so I brought in some Heavy
Hitters the NFL is here you got UFC MLB
college football let the pros help you
out so you make bank they are expert
Pickers that's what they do these guys
know exactly who to bet on the parlays
all the odds they're the best in the
business that's why I partner up with
fancy Guru don't take pics from me Drake
or Channel zoning anymore all you got to
do is go to fancyguru.com use the promo
code shop schab you get 20 off 20 off
that's nothing and he hit the best picks
from the NFL UFC MLB NCAA it's fancy
Guru or bus go to fancyguru.com promo
code is shop for 20 off now let's start
the program
Mr chal sonen what is going on my man we
got the the government's discovered
aliens we got Taylor Swift dating Travis
Kelsey and then also Sean Strickland
defeated Izzy arasania what is the world
coming to my man
apparently in Mexico they discovered
this alien I'm not buying it I think
it's all a distraction of everything
else going on this they found this
little kind of weak alien thing
mummified alien it I don't know if
that's an alien I'm not scared of it man
right it's always mummified or broad
what's up a farmer's ass like it's
always the same story you're gonna
one at some point even a photo will do
but there's gonna have to be something
tangible yeah you'll see this thing it's
clearly I don't know if it's you know
made uh
in a lab this thing looks weird I'm not
scared of it if that's what they look
like sign me up man it says it's a
thousand year old alien Corp so I'm
looking at right now it looks like a
it'll bum you out if you're big into
aliens and this shows up it's gonna bum
you out it's a real look down I feel
like there's been presidents that have
tried to tell us like I do feel like
Donald Trump did an interview one time
and he got as close as anybody to to
revealing to the world and Obama was an
interesting one he I think it was he was
doing David Letterman and Obama's that
made some statement that you've heard it
a hundred times David Letterman responds
that's what every President says and
Obama says yes that's what they that's
what they want us to tell you and
everybody got this really big laugh
except it felt like a real
moment I'll give you one you might be
too young to know but when Bill Clinton
ran was 1992 was the first time he was
elected but in the late 80s early 90s
the phenomenon of aliens was everywhere
if you were in the checkout line or
something like this all the tabloids all
alien all the time and Clinton said he
got asked a question about him and he
said I've always wanted to know that too
and if I'm elected I will get back to
you I will answer your question he got
elected and he never spoke about it
again even when people brought it up and
I know that no evidence isn't the case
of evidence but it does feel as though
there's at least a phenomenon agree yeah
they've tried this numerous times it's
also like with the JFK assassination
Trump was like I'm gonna be the first
president I'm gonna release the files
and then he has access to do it he goes
all right I'm gonna release a certain
amount of the files not all of them
because I don't think the public can
handle what what else is in there it's
like well what is going on here man so I
think they have good intentions then
they get to the top and people are like
you can't but you just can't give all
that information out that one was an
incredible one it was something about
70. I can't remember now if it was 70
000 Pages or 70 pages but Trump did
order it and the head of the CIA was a
female at that time I can't remember her
name but she refused and Trump said I'm
giving you an executive order release
these and she refused so they brought
Trump in to explain all the reasons why
it needed to be redacted or why they
couldn't put it out and ultimately it
did just die she overrode the president
which was also very interesting I mean
that's that one's clearance date that
and Aliens I the whole aliens thing
freaks me out hopefully we find out are
you more surprised that Mexico found in
alien or Sean Strickland beat Izzy
they're they're equal in many ways Sean
Strickland dominated Israel a lot of
sunny and let me tell you how I watched
this fight by the way I watched I was at
an amateur show that was live earlier in
the day I'm an ordained minister I
married my wife's brother so I got a few
things going on I finally sit down I'm
at this amateur event though and I'm
I've got it on my phone so I'm watching
the event I'm looking down I'm watching
the event I'm looking down but I know
Izzy's winning because every time I look
down they're on their feet so like 25
minutes later and I did see the
knockdown I watched with Sean knocked
him down the first round and swarmed him
which generally if you go for a finish
like that in the first round you're not
going to win a decision your gas tank is
empty so my deduction of just looking
down and knowing it was a pure
kickboxing match also tells me that
otisanya won and when they raised Sean's
hand like my God I gotta go back and
watch this not only did Sean beat him he
beat him at his own game that part's
pretty interesting yet the biggest
surprise to me and I mean you and I are
the only ones that called in the
business we had Strickland winning this
thing you know with you me and you know
Drake was way off but um I think the
most surprising thing is if Monday
morning told me hey Strickland won okay
would he catch him he caught him in the
first round and knocked him down and got
a lucky submission or something like
that and if you told me no for 25
minutes it stayed on its feet and
Strickland out struck him uh completely
dominated Izzy was only a uh labeled a
land 22 head punches in 25 minutes I
mean I would have called you a liar I
would have bet my house on it you know
so I just think it to me it's the
biggest upset of all time because the
weight went down matt Sarah GSP things
happen flukes happen I get that and also
GSP when he did lose that fight wasn't
the same magnitude as a star or reigning
champ as Izzy was so I give Strickland
the nod over that so I I guess I was
just surprised the way that Strickland
completely dominated and also his
defense his defense was
insane man absolutely insane and to your
point about that like they'll tell you
all your shoes is from an amateur
wrestling background but they'll tell
you that a pen is the most dominant
thing you can do but I'll tell you as a
wrestler if you get Bender you pin
somebody the fellow wrestlers go will
you caught him I mean that 10 years
later hey remember that time you caught
me and pinned me and I feel like the
knockout's the same way and I'm speaking
more to doing the rematch they say we're
going to do an immediate rematch
generally when we do immediate rematches
somebody got caught I would argue that
aljo got caught aljo had one completed
round and he won that round he takes one
shot he goes down a lot of those are the
ones go hey we got to see that again
this was so dominant not to mention in
the realm and Izzy didn't handle this
like any former Champion I mean they all
come out with the same story oh my hand
was broken I just went through Camp
anyway I didn't want to let you fans
down I mean it's the same story every
time easy to tell that story he he took
it like a man he said you know we
thought it was a fair fight this guy won
I appreciated that side of it but there
wasn't something about that match that
lends to a rematch
I rather stand the star of the business
I get why we're doing it I just think
that it's a little more glaringly
obvious in this case and normally we
would try to hide that a little bit
better
I agree it's kind of like the Amanda
Nunez and the Pena fight they fought the
first time you know Pena did her thing
the second one was an absolute you know
there's ten eight rounds and Amanda
Nunes completely destroyed her okay well
let's go for a third it's one one nope
it's not justified that we're good if
someone completely dominates like that
it doesn't justify a rematch and I'm the
biggest Izzy fan I'm a Big Sean
Strickland fan too but for Izzy it's it
was hard for me to come on the show
Monday and go I'm not all for the
rematch because it was a 25 minute
domination it was it it it you know I
Rogan and I were watching it doing the
fight campaign Rogan Sam tripley me and
Callan we had it 5-0 there's argument
4-1 sure I'll entertain four one outside
that you're not giving Izzy a single
freaking round so the rematch just isn't
there for me if you're Dana White and I
get the business aspect of it is he's a
massive star he's probably the biggest
star you know not named Conor McGregor
so so we know is he's a massive star
he's good for business
so we see why they would do immediate
rematch but I there's something to it
where the new matchups the new blood in
the division is exciting you know so if
I'm Dana and
also I want your thoughts on this if I'm
Dana Izzy needs to rest you know this as
well as anybody when you're a champion
you have to do different things that
these other contenders don't have to do
you're selling the pay-per-view heavy
lies the crown it's exhausting and
Izzy's very active as a champ might be
the most active champ I've seen in my
lifetime he's active as hell he's
fighting the top guys day in day out and
then he's also responsible for selling
the paper you because he's BD ever be it
everybody you know and people are
prisoners of the moment they go ah he
was never that good no you're getting
confused he's so good he lapped the
middleweight division hit that they had
to do rematches and he beat those guys
so those people are just president of
the moment but I I do think there's
something with Izzy where he it didn't
look like our typical Izzy now I'm not
taking anything away from Sean
Strickland maybe maybe you know Sean
Strickland just has his number okay but
it didn't look like our normal is he
looked tired I think he being active as
the champion being that active at that
high of a level he just needs a break
and he can come back fight through
policies even if it's not for a title
I'm in for that but I I just think Izzy
could use a break let the division build
other stars and then come back
I certainly wouldn't have a problem with
that you know anytime you do a rematch
you're going to get asked the same
question and the answer doesn't overly
matter you just have to have an answer
but what's going to be different this
time and that is where it gets
complicated I mean they fought that
fight where is he wanted to fight it
there's not going to be a make-believe
interview that is he comes out and says
well I knew I should have taken him down
I know I should have pinned him up
against the fence and dropped my elbows
like that's where I think that it gets a
little bit tough as a selling feature
nothing went wrong in that fight
Everything went perfect and for whatever
reason Sean Strickland was better at it
than Izzy was and and I do feel like
imagine that Izzy does say and he goes
oh no nothing's going to change I'm
going to do the same thing I'm just
gonna do it better you go it's kind of a
weird one because Brandon the only
reason it gets weird what happens if
Izzy comes back and beats him which
right now he's the favorite the new line
came out he's a minus 120 he went off at
a minus 600 but he's still a favorite
even his slide what if he beats him
something tells me we don't go to the
trilogy something tells me if we get the
belt back around Izzy we don't extend
the same favorite as Sean that Sean's
gonna have to show to autosonya and I
just think that that adds to your point
maybe it's time to take your oars out of
the water let that division build Izzy
has set himself a number of times that
he would like parody he would like some
different matchups he's tired of being
in there with the same guys I mean how
many times did he fight Pierre I believe
it was four times in total correct and
it's just it gets to an interesting
point you know what do you do with
duplicity I know he's sitting there
thinking he's the number one Contender
but in a month we're gonna have Jemiah
and Paulo Costa they're going to come
steal a lot of Thunder they're going to
get built up I'm quite sure before that
fight goes off they're going to announce
that this is the number one contenders
match and it just feels as though the
police is going to need uh something to
do and him fighting without a Sonia not
for a title I love it what's the
difference in many ways what's the
difference if they have a problem with
each other they never said it was about
the belt in the first place they just
want to fight the fight still works they
can still do it
I agree but if you're a duplicity's
management you know and let's say Izzy
needs a break if you're duplicates can
you afford to sit out and be out of the
public eye be out of the kind of the the
MMA fight talk for seven months six
months can depletes afford that or does
he take on a guy like Canon there and
stay active and become undeniable
yeah no that's a tough one I I don't
know I mean I've had that same question
as it pertains to Michael Chandler like
whatever is going on with Conor McGregor
it does not appear that he's going to be
fighting anytime soon and if we're to
listen to usada the day he decides he's
gonna fight that's when a sixth six
month clock starts I mean half of a year
at some point Chandler's got to put his
his foot down and Brendan that fight by
the way and I know I'm jumping around
but that fight has felt very weird I was
on my way to fedor's retirement fight
against Ryan Bader I remember where I
was when I got the news it was going to
be Chandler versus McGregor and it
didn't feel right from Jump Street then
they got Dana Chandler and Connor and
three different people interviewed them
they don't know the interviews going on
so they're all giving different answers
Chandler says we're doing it 55.
McGregor says we're doing it at 70 and
Dana says we haven't found a weight
class yet if you don't even know what
weight class you're doing it at there is
no fight and they went from there
continued to say there was one went off
to The Ultimate Fighter Conor McGregor
now according to Social Media which I
get that he's a troll but most recently
says we're gonna do it at 185. and
Chandler instantly responds and goes
great let's do it it's like Mike at some
point
you don't have to look so willing at
some point somebody here is gonna have
to play hardball or nothing if nothing
changes then the outcome doesn't change
and the outcome right now is you guys
aren't fighting
agree that fight from the jump has
always been a little strange to to your
point we've never seen anything kind of
that get you know our my boy Casey who's
my producer he's the biggest Conor fan
I'm a huge Conor fan too
you know gun to the heads of the fight
happen I don't know I still eat to this
day they went through the ultimate
fighter you know they've talked about 55
70 85 I just don't see it happen and
again to your point Chandler needs to
find just go I just need to fight and I
think you know it's like when you're
chasing the hot girl the more desperate
you are the more they're like no I'm
good man you know so I think Channel
needs to play a little hard to get and
go you know I'm gonna move on UFC give
me another fight and see how Connor
reacts be the hot girl in school be the
hot girl in school and I think as it
pertains to Strickland and Izzy
you know what the the thing that I think
about is is strickling way better than
we thought is he that damn good or did
Izzy have an off night without taking
away you know what Strickland did is
Strickland that damn good and we just
didn't see it when you go back over his
record you're like all right that looks
pretty good there well that last fight
he did look damn when you think about it
he looked pretty good you know you go
through his losses and you know we've
talked about this off air Strickland
used to come into Reign and you have a
story how you know he would come in
there and he said he was King of the
cage champ I don't remember him well in
those days I remember a little bit but
he's always been kind of you know when
he came into the UFC he was kind of this
blue chip recruitment he was a big deal
fell off a little bit for the reason and
then now he's back so I guess what I
struggle with is Strickland that damn
good or did Izzy just have one of those
nights
or is it a combination of both
it's really hard right like I respect
kickboxing I I've sparred with Joe
schillingham before and really felt like
wow this these high level guys and the
Rhythm they have and the techniques that
they have I mean I really respect that
Sean Strickland for the most part I
think is self-trained I've never heard
him talk about you know the day at eight
years old my dad dropped me off at
Freddy roach's gym or something like
this I've never really heard that that
goes with his wrestling his Jujitsu too
you know he's just kind of one of these
tough guys so I would have to think that
autosanya is better but that's not what
we saw right there was something awkward
about Sean Strickland they did a stat on
Sean it was many fights ago I want to
say he was uh fighting Jack her Manson
but the announce team puts out a stat
that Sean Strickland is the greatest
defense in the middleweight division to
show you what their math was they just
looked at how many punches were thrown
at middleweights how many landed verses
did it land and Sean Strickland had the
highest he's very hard to hit you know
he comes in with this stance and you've
never seen an MMA fighter Sean
Strickland and Chuck Liddell are the
only ones that have the This Dance
everybody else gets clipped and they got
caught they got to keep their hands up
so he is very unique I think that he
surprised himself every now and then a
fighter gets in a fight that isn't as
hard as he thought it was going to be
like I maintained to this day there was
nobody more surprised that Justin gate
she'd beat Tony Ferguson than Justin
gaichi and I think that Sean just
started to feel that momentum in many
ways it wasn't the fight he was supposed
to fight he didn't threaten the takedown
by example he didn't get to the clinch
he didn't put any major effort into get
the takedown to start with which is what
we all thought he was gonna have to do
it was a very lazy approach back to 1993
of Grappler versus Striker but it still
didn't happen it's like Sean did
everything that that Izzy wanted to do
and so how high level do you have to be
I mean I gotta look at that and I
instantly think about Francis and fury
and go well maybe it's not quite as hard
as we think it is maybe you get a guy
that's a little awkward it does stuff
you're not used to I mean there's a lot
of things that I'm accepting but he has
to see that Sean Strickland was a better
Striker than honest Sonia I thought that
that was that was mind-blowing yeah
maybe we're overthinking it maybe we're
making the fight game too complicated
you know you try and make it like the
NFL or like baseball where a lot goes
into it a lot of planning goes into it
and then the day it's just two dudes
fighting you know we're and and Sean
Strickland's able to break it down and
meet potatoes and you know he spars more
than anybody and there's been this trend
you know the same as the NFL you know
Tampa 2 coverage was successful so the
rest of the teams did that for the next
five years until we had until they
adapted a running quarterback they did
that forever so it's a copycat League
the UFC is the same you know so I think
I'm gonna be curious to see if Fighters
go look at Sean Strickland he's the
champ man all he does is Spar forget all
this technique we've been doing let's
just Spar and I don't know if that's a
good thing I think it works with Sean
Strickland I don't know if it's gonna
work for everybody else and I'm also
curious I want your thoughts on this
channel you know your marketing genius
some would say you you look at your
career and the way you you know mix it
up and became Infamous for a variety of
reasons in your fight prayer
what is the UFC marking team Monday
morning when they sat around did are
they like we got one we got here's the
guy it was chantra he's different now
here's how he's different and and I
think there's a way they can they can
run with this I think in a world of
these gimmicks that were limited you
know you click on YouTube it's you know
you know Chael son and you know wrestles
two gay two two gay guys naked and you
click on it you just wrestling you know
at some Camp there's nothing to it so
there's all this fake smoke out there
there's AI coming there there's all this
fake you know what I'm saying there's
Instagram it's not real Sean Strickland
is authentic as they get and I think and
he and he kind of he attracts a certain
fan base who are who are they don't have
a lot of Heroes you know a poor white
kid grew up from nothing and he talks
about this and you know former you know
Neo-Nazi and all this horrible
background you know horrible father
horrible parents and he's made it and
he's he's their Champion I think there's
a way to Market this because the the
masses are appealing to to Sean
Strickland and I think if they just take
away you know obviously he's gonna say
some off-putting stuff I don't agree
with everything he says but what I do
agree with he's authentic and that's
what people they're starving for it in
comedy and podcasting and they're
athletes how many times do we see a UFC
fighter NFL guy go you know it is a
perfect game plan and respect and then
you know I'm just whoever's next we
don't want to hear that tell us how you
feel man Sean Strickland is going to
tell you how he feels the UFC just has
to let him do his thing he might not
bring on the big Nike sponsors and the
the Burger Kings of the world but he's
what he is going to do is appeal to a
mass mass audience so I I think it's a
good thing if they let Shawn Strickland
do his thing are you worried about it
well to your point when people sure do
appear to be attracted to it like there
his Crowds Are massive I mean he almost
had a rocky moment where he he flipped
the Australian crowd which appears to be
a pretty cool crowd to start with I must
say I mean they're pretty opening and
inviting but you know even on a son
who's clapping for him at the end yeah
I'm a little worried about it I mean
early in his career and I say this to
somebody because he wasn't at rain where
you know I do have a care for him and
wants him to do good things I was a
little nervous they're not going to be
able to put him in these massive spots
just because they can't give him a main
event just because they can't have him
doing media but he has found a way to
navigate that and there is something uh
that does seem very real you know he was
talking about the belt and saying that
you know the Belt doesn't matter then he
asks somebody how much can I get for it
and somebody told him 1700 bucks and
he's like that's not even enough money
to put Spinners on my Honda accent or it
was just it was one of these things but
everything that he does does work in
terms of being a real guy I think that
he's the least likely to you know be
pulling up in a Ferrari tomorrow or over
spinning on a big house or stop going to
practice because he's at the cool party
there is something very real about him
he's rough as hell he's Rough Around the
Edges but he's also the champion of the
world and you know in America the number
one things that matter is Success he's
found it I mean this guy's gonna be
really really big I'd love to see if he
pushed back on honest on him and I get
why you do the rematch I would just love
to see where where his power lies and
Brandon can I tell you my favorite fight
going on right now nobody's talking
about this but for me my favorite fight
is for main event on the December
pay-per-view all the rest of the
pay-per-views of the year have been
announced but for the December card you
know Conor McGregor going to social
media declaring that he's fighting
Chandler now Conor's at least serious
that he wants that date it looks like
they're not going to give it to him but
he wants it Leon and Colby are supposed
to fight this year and the clock's
ticking that would mean that they've got
a fight on the December date vulcanovsky
has change course and said I'm no longer
interested in doing Islam because I
would have to wait until 24 and I want
to fight to pour it this year so that
would put him on the December date and
then Sean O'Malley before he leaves the
link ring against Sterling not only
calls for Cheeto Vera but he calls
specifically for the December date so it
really is interesting to find out who's
got the power and who the biggest star
is and there's some of these guys that
are all going for the same thing it
won't get talked about it look the same
I hope that I'm setting this up well
because it really is interesting all
these guys are flexing behind the scenes
none of those guys want to be a co-man
event right I mean you've got you've got
four Champions someone's gonna have to
co-main an event they're all gonna have
to co-main event if Connor steps forward
I just think it's an interesting thing
and O'Malley does have some news coming
I have to assume that news means a fight
if he's got a fight I have to assume
December but if he gets it look at the
guys that he just beat out the USC has
their choice of Champions whoever they
go with in December that's saying a lot
it's saying this is the guy we think can
move the needle and I assume that's
sugar especially you know with without
him saying he has news I would assume
that sugar when all those names that you
you listed there as far as when it comes
to markability selling pay-per-views I
assume that's sugar and do you assume
it's Cheeto
I assume it'd be him versus Cheeto yeah
I think alju's historically speaking I
think he's owed a rematch generally if
you get caught you do a rematch anytime
you're hit with one punch and you go
down that goes into the criteria's cop
plus I think he had set a record with
defenses even though it was only a
couple but bantamweight it's it's such a
a musical chairs over there
aljo did make one mistake though which
is he didn't ask for the rematch he did
not in the ring ask for it so Sean moved
on to Cheeto cheetah was there the press
conference is in the back he got all
three players there it seemed like maybe
he did things in the in the wrong order
but I don't think that that aljo going
to social media is going to be able to
build a fire as much as the one that he
smoldered live in the ring and I don't
think he's next and I don't think I
don't think morale playing the game up
I'm not going to fight aljo I don't
think Henry's in the discussion even as
great as he is yes I think it's Cheeto
me too I agree I think it's Geo in
December there's also a case too you
know Strickland didn't have a scratch on
him and stricken likes to stay Super
Active so him being champion and he he
doesn't seem like a guy
who's gonna you know hold the bell and
and pick his opponent I think he's down
to dance with whoever whether it's
hamzat Pollo Costa the rematch
duplicates he doesn't care if he if if
we're going based off the way he's
carried himself leading up to become a
champion so I think with Strickland
there is a possibility where he goes I I
want to turn around fast like I've
always done I want I want to fight right
away who's available to police he's cool
we don't know where he's at with his
injury uh obviously Paulo Costa and uh
hamzat they're fighting October there's
no way they fight in December less you
know hom's otter Polo Casa is a quick
one quick turnaround you know it's a
One-Shot uh night night's over type of
fight but I'm curious how Strickland
acts as a champion now is he going to
carry the same energy how active he is
you know because he did to him I don't
think the title obviously it's not
filming whatever hole he has going on
there in his soul you know just doesn't
he didn't seem like the type of guy the
guy that gets the belt and he's gonna
call his shots I think he's giving you
know a good company man and that's not a
knock on him that it goes a long ways
when you do that so I think he's gonna
be an active champ so there's a
possibility he could be on that December
card if duplicates which I don't know
where he's at you want to talk about
duplicity you want to out not taking
advantage of our opportunity they
offered you a title shot dude you have
to and I bet he was watching that fight
going oh no I could have beat this guy
and now you know who knows he might get
left behind yeah no I hear you on that
and that was a very that was a very
interesting case as it was I mean just a
quick timeline but go back to December
10th that is when prohaska was supposed
to rematch go over to share they were
going to do it for the Bell prohaska
gets hurt they not only they not only
don't do the fight they take the belt
off him which I I found that to be
shocking by the way one week after he
announces he's heard he's no longer
Champion if you're gonna strip a guy
that kind of says you don't think he's
ever going to come back and it was even
stated this is the worst shoulder injury
we've ever said so they took the belt
off a guy while simultaneously having a
heavyweight that had ACL surgery sat for
10 months and there was never even a
threat they were going to take the belt
off him I just think that that's
interesting they put new two new guys in
by January prohaska says I'm ready I can
go back in and it's like okay I believe
you perovska because you're the one that
told us in the first place that you were
hurt but what do we chalk this up to is
this a misdiagnosis that'd be great is
this a miracle like what is it that
where you were stripped in December but
you're back by January now you've got
all of this time that's gone by and
allegedly again he's back but there's no
rumor of an opponent there's no rumor of
a return date like I just think that
it's a very interesting case with
prohaska it gets revealed to us by usada
then they tested it 25 times in 27 days
which had never happened before nothing
was flagged and nothing came back but at
the same time we don't hear anything
about prohaska to the point that when
Jamal wins the belt in January you would
think it'd be somewhat quick turnaround
Jamal gets hurt and dropped the bell in
July seven months later but again he
didn't have a fight booked there wasn't
even a rumor of an opponent for Jamal so
and where I'm going with all of this is
the fact that if they do turn Strickland
around the way they are turning O'Malley
around like some of these guys can't get
fights that are champions some of these
guys can't stay out of the cage they've
got to act him they've got him busy all
the time sometimes that attitude is good
and sometimes I mean I'm just sharing
with you like there is a lot of politics
this goes into it there's a lot of
numbers that that we don't see but it's
also kind of put right in front of us
they nothing happened with those light
heavyweights and those light heavy whims
won't sell out in the Arenas all of a
sudden bantamweight is rising up all of
a sudden Sean Strickland is a champion
of the world he's on a different
continent he's got 17 000 people on
their feet cheering it's a very
different time and all of this goes on
with an overlaying story of it appears
Conor McGregor is not as needed as he
once was you've got Conor McGregor
begging to come back he's serious about
that he wanted that December date he
wants to get in there he knows he's not
playing ball but he thinks that there's
a clause in the contract that could be
activated in his favor which Conor is
right in my opinion there is a clause
and he doesn't have to do 180 days but
now the question comes is the UFC want
to take on their Partners in usada over
a guy that doesn't move the needle that
much more than the new guys red panda
Knight is still real Conor's still the
biggest star it just appears that it's
closing we're at a very different time
in MMA Brendan very different down there
when we're compete my man I think it's
also interesting too if you're Alex
Pierre
uh you know he has a win over Izzy has a
win over Strickland let's say he goes
out there and beats yerry if there's
something in Alex Pierre where he goes
you know what now that Izzy's not the
champ I'm gonna go back to I'm gonna be
the double champ Champ here I'm gonna go
back to middleweight if it's strictly
I'm very beat him if it's homside you
know if it's whoever it is Robert
Whittaker duplicies I think Alex Pierce
looking going I would beat any of these
guys this is easy to get another belt I
could see that happening it's a good
time in the business good time for what
we do I I think you know for what we do
is he you know as much as I love is he
him losing and Strickland being him I
was excited to come in the studio money
because if he would have just walked
through him there's not a lot to talk
about you know so I wasn't mad at that
in in any facet you would know probably
better than most this this WWE merger
which was announced yesterday with the
UFC and they rang the bell at NASDAQ
how do you see you this is a good thing
I think they're evaluated at 21 billion
now uh the TKO Group which is the name
of the WWE in the UFC they're they're
one uh kind of company now I think it
gives them power as far as TV ratings
and TV deals you know I think I don't
know how much longer UFC has with ESPN
or WWE has with Fox but I could see them
making some big waves when it when those
Deal TV deals are up and that's where
they get their main nut so it's gonna be
interesting to see how they kind of use
that power that they have now merging
together the WWE 21 billion dollar
company I'm curious how it's going to go
I think all good but I I think where it
gets a little
murky is
the Casual fan I think it's hard for
them to separate hold on so you're
telling me you know Roman Reigns and
Izzy under the same Banner so as Roman
Reigns can be fighting you know insert
Jon Jones is that is that how this goes
so it gets a little weird I think I
think they do have to keep them separate
but I think it could be good
I I'm dying with Curiosity on that as
well right like nobody buys a company of
of any size 21 billion or or 200 to keep
it the same they all go because they see
opportunity to make it grow and that's
where I'm so curious I mean Ari might
change the way TV is done if like
getting these two together what are they
going to do their own network maybe
they've got the WWE Network they've got
Fight Pass but is it something along
those lines or are they just going to
keep going to the highest bidder but I
mean not for nothing what would stop
baseball and football from teaming up
like if whatever plan already has
actually works and you can make more
money having both as opposed to
separates I mean I will tell you it's
it's a different level of business but
he's also up to something that hasn't
been seen before it's it's not black and
white and there's not an example we go
yeah this was done in 1980 with the such
and such it's never been done and I
don't know where he plans to go with it
I'm I'm extremely curious I remember
that you know Dana when he started doing
weekly shows people all pushed back said
that's too much and Dana said is there
too much football like like if you're a
fan there's there's not too much once a
week is enough you know the Seinfeld go
too often whatever examples Dana gave
but he turned out to be right turned out
there was an audience turned out people
did like to do that on Saturday turn
their TV on and and watch it and by the
way I'm jumping around but you brought
him to please just a minute ago I lost
my train of thought but I've rebound it
where I was talking about on duplication
the reason I went back to that December
show with the light heavyweights I
didn't know who the police he was he had
a very beautiful name freak is too crazy
I assumed he was French and people were
calling him like DDP kind of like GSP
there's Audi South uh African I had the
whole thing wrong but I shared that with
you because I didn't know who he was he
was on the undercar I agree and that
night way back in December same weight
class of 185 Bo nickel was to be on the
main card in the debut debut and drink
his duplicity lost his mind he went on
Twitter and he was telling everybody how
can I with all these fights and all that
I've done have to jerk the curtain for
this guy making a debut and if you think
it's a skill issue then just put me in
there with him I will fight him but I'm
taking that main card spot you had the
light heavyweight to get hurt you had a
shuffle of the deck the squeaky wheel
gets the grease into policy comes up but
this is an incredible rain to go from
under card in December to right now he
was supposed to have fought for the
world title on a brand new television
network in front of a sold out Arena I
mean it was a really big difference and
as he starts getting his come UPS they
go okay you're gonna have to prove it
here's the hardest guy we have not named
Izzy his name is Robert Whittaker and
nobody not named Izzy has been able to
deal with this guy
goes out there he beats him he looked
like a top five ever I don't know five
middleweights ever that could beat that
guy that Whitaker had to deal with
everything's going his way and we all
knew going in if he wins he's going to
go in September on this brand new
television deal opposite autosonya
hosted in Australia like all of these
things were put in place to the extent
that they flew Izzy and sat him in the
front row because he knew he was going
to come face to face with whoever the
winner was
something happened within that interview
if you watch the body language of
duplicity something happened they keep a
camera on him they fade to black roll
the credits but now you can go over the
Internet they show him coming through
the curtain he's still sweaty hasn't put
a t-shirt on they're gonna take his
gloves and and decompose them they're
going to hand him his check all those
things that you do somebody puts a
camera on him and the very first thing
he says when they ask him about his new
fight with audacity is I want to talk
about Robert Whittaker so they go to the
Whitaker thing and they ask him again
and he says you know I'd rather not talk
about Izzy I think I'd like to talk
about Robert Whittaker so then he goes
to the press conference and now he does
have his shirt on but he's still sweaty
he's still hot in the moment they ask
him about autism it was one of those
extremely rare occasions right every
time you go to a press conference Dana
has to say the same thing as well let's
see what will happen it's extremely
anticlimactic this is one of the very
few times we know what's going to happen
the whole reason we held this fight is
to know what's going to happen and he
says it a third time I don't want to
talk about him I want to talk about
sharing the cage with Whitaker and I've
got some I've got some injuries I've got
some things I might want to rehab think
man you got the right to do that however
you want but every fighter in history
would tell you right there in the moment
they'd hold up their foot and go my god
look how swollen this thing is ah I'm
gonna have to get with my dog I want to
do that fight but no I got to get some
ice on this he had like these mystery
injuries that he never disclosed he took
a couple of days to get his head around
it decided to defer to a foot and I'm
just it didn't feel right and I'm not
accusing him of Faking a fight to get
out of that I know that he faked the
injury what I'm saying is sometimes you
can't run those back right like it's
really hard to imagine to policies
against Strickland the UFC is going to
go okay we're going to give you a chance
to fight a guy who did what you were
unwilling to do he shocked the world in
doing it but we're going to give you a
chance to go in and steal his thunder
without ever having to do the one thing
that you really didn't want to do and it
just doesn't work that way I can't think
of time in history where it worked that
way and I bring it to you because he
thinks he's the number one Contender I
don't disagreement he's a total stud
whatever got in the way though it got in
the way and I don't think there's any
way to get to a bell if your name is
duplicity's without going through Auto
Sonic so whether you can get him now as
both of you are contenders or you got to
wait your turn until he becomes Champion
you got to do it again I don't think
there's any scenario where the UFC
allows du policy to be Champion unless
he goes through autosanya I agree 100
and I I don't know what's going on there
but I do think do policies too you know
he whenever you turn down A Moment Like
This even if you even if you're hurt
let's say you know he's actually hurt
by turning that down Dana does not for
you know this better anyone especially
me Dana doesn't reward that they're not
going to reward you with a title shot
with Strickland because you turn down
the fight against Izzy I just don't see
the UFC rewarding it even though the fan
base I see a lot of you know DDP DB DDP
for the you know let him fight
Strickland there's just no way Dana's
gonna reward him turning down a fight to
get you know on paper an easier fight at
the title shot to your point I don't see
it happening I just don't people like oh
what's your what's your issue with DDP I
have no issue with I think he's
phenomenal fighter he's so awkward he's
gonna be a tough night in the office for
anybody my issue is the way he's carried
himself since he's beat Whitaker now it
might not be him maybe it's someone in
his ear maybe it's his team but either
way over history Dana doesn't reward
that stuff so I'm going based off that I
think the Apollo Costa hamzat is going
to get the next Shot Hands Down Bar None
I think they announced that
well and what an interesting one that
one has I mean not for nothing but Paulo
Costa constant shamayo gets made like
five months ago Apollo Casa is going
through a contract dispute they get the
contract done and they give him in
October on fight Island great
everybody's running with that you could
ask either one of those guys or their
campers to their trainers or their
girlfriends for that matter everybody
knows that's the fight it never gets
announced officially and then all of a
sudden for Salt Lake City Paul Lucas is
going to come and fight with a Russian
gentleman now don't condescend I don't
know how to say the guy's name I'm going
to call him a Russian gentleman so
they're going to fight that's returning
Paul Lucas to the Salt Lake that's where
he had that knock down drag out with
Luke rockhold that was rubbing the blood
on it tough fight they tried to pad that
card get some ticket sales that's a guy
they return them home fine now
Jeremiah's left with nobody to the point
that it looked like Jared Cannon here
purely because nobody else would do the
job all right fine one week before
you're supposed to get on the plane so
training camp is done the weight loss
for the most part is done one week
before Paulo cost is supposed to board a
plane in Brazil and fly to Salt Lake the
U.S she pulls that fight and they keep
the Russian on the car they give him a
new opponent but they pulled Paul Acosta
and in the history of the UFC I've seen
them lose fights somebody gets sick
somebody concerned I know that they
change things I've never seen them break
up a fight they try to bring the card to
the audience as close to what they they
said they were going to do as possible
so they pulled Paul Acosta and then it
gets revealed he's not hurting he's not
sick he's gonna go fight your mind in
October and fight Island which was the
initial plan to start with they got in
their own way realize we need to do it
over here and they do it over here but
imagine this Brandon if you're Apollo
Costa your manager has done his job your
coaches have done his job all your
sparring partners have done their job
they're going to want to get paid so all
of a sudden you get a call all the work
that you've done without illness or
injury or fault to you we're taking it
back and you're gonna go do it in
October I don't think you could get a
yes out of him unless you sweeten the
pot and to sweeten the pot means you
promised him this would be a number one
contenders I think that promise has
already been made it's been stated
publicly By Dana that if chimaya
declares 185 which is to be identified
by let's 170 go and he has one victory
that he will then go on to fight for the
Bell so it just looks like that's the
number one contenders match I think the
duplicities is a floating Target I think
he's out there the night that he argued
that Bo nickel shouldn't be on Pay Per
View and he should or that at the same
night that he said all fight bow nickel
it seems like there's an opportunity
right now like if you're a boat nickel
you're not getting a world title fight
it doesn't matter who the opponent is
you're not getting that opportunity why
not go get the next best thing though
why not go get a guy that's in line it
just seems like four middleweights if
they could open their eyes and see
what's going on in their landscape
there's a lot of guys to go after
there's a lot of guys that could put you
in a position to then eventually leave
for the title and that was one thing
that was cool about Sean Strickland he
never talked about the Bell he just
talked about opportunities if the Bell
happened to be a byproduct okay fine but
it's one of the reasons Wes is six to
one Underdog we were still willing to
come along the journey we're still doing
to watch him because it was never about
the belt he wants to beat this guy for
whatever his reasons well I actually
missed the whole Chinese thing I know
that he he brought that into it I don't
actually know what he's referencing I
think it was like a commercial or
something do you know the Chinese
stories that pertains not a Sonia I
heard it second hand but from what what
I heard is is he proclaimed his love for
China because Izzy used to have a some
sort of contract with China with
kickboxing and he went over there and
just loved the culture and the obviously
he's embraced over there so he wore the
he wore the Chinese color you know
shorts
um uh and again that I forgot to mention
this I think part of the reason what
made trickling so big and so lovable in
this was a lot of mistakes by Izzy take
your take off the in in lockdown as he
made a lot of mistakes I think the way
the marketing he had some miscues you
know with the whole dog stuff was a
little strange a little off-putting I
think for people and then also the
Chinese shorts now we know for the most
part unless you're living in a rock
Izzy's not Australian you know Izzy is
not Australian but he sure as hell not
Chinese so I think it was a total
miscalculation on Izzy's part to
represent the Chinese colors and I think
that put the Australian fans who you
know is he again isn't Australian I
think that put a lot more chips in
Strickland's Corner that they and you
saw the the Applause that he got and
then if you watch the broadcast and you
turn the volume up is he's getting quite
amount of booze when he's walking out to
the Octagon there's a lot of booze and I
think if you're not familiar with the
story why are they booing Izzy it's
because there's a lot of miscalculations
leading up to this fight people didn't
like a lot of things that he was doing
so again that that I think adds value to
him getting arrest taking a long break
let people forget about this let the
division figure itself out and then jump
back in but my question for you to Beau
nickel there's nobody I'm higher on you
know I'm all up on bows nuts I'm on
Hamza Terry nuts I love both guys
if you're Beau Nichols management what
are you telling him you're telling him
let's shoot for the stars here you're
ready to take on a a duplicity because
he beats him we're probably going title
next do you think he's ready for that or
does he need one or two more maybe in
the you know outside of the top five
because I know where my head's at my
head is pretty high question because you
said if you're the management so I mean
if you're the management I think you sit
back and go Bo it pays the same Bo is
the biggest favorite in UFC history for
his last fight
2400 right biggest ever a no fight has
ever gone but if you're the managers you
would say Bo it pays the same to take on
the top guys or to fight these guys that
they're signing just to fight you your
of the night bonuses and your
eligibility for that all of this pays
the same I believe you can beat all of
the tough guys why bother you haven't
left the first round yet and you're
getting the same paychecks as if you
would if you were a co-man event I mean
not for nothing Bo's in a pretty sweet
spot now Bo the competitor yes I've
known him basically his whole life of
course he wants to go in and do some of
those big matches he doesn't know quite
how to get him and he does have a code
he's a very polite he's a gentleman and
he's not willing to to sell that part of
himself for the business so it's going
to be a little bit of a longer path but
it just does seem like there is some
massive opportunity I mean duplicity
just called him out that was in December
they placed him on the same car Beau was
ahead I mean not for nothing you can't
say that doesn't qualify for duplicity
qualified for the same card and whoever
placed it put in three spots above him
somebody already thinks he's done a good
job not to mention he hasn't lost since
I just think there's opportunity to go
after some of these other guys and I
feel that people miss it I'll use an
example which is Henry sahuto Henry
knows he's not going to get Sean
O'Malley right now so Henry's trying to
get murab it's not because he wants to
fight marap he just realizes if I can't
get this let me get the next best thing
which will put me in line for something
else and I feel like that that's a mess
all the time where guys go after you
know the head guy but now they got
competition five other guys are going
for him too nobody ever goes after the
number one Contender or the really smart
guys would have hedged their bet a week
ago and they've called out Sean
Strickland nobody thought Sean had a
chance so nobody did it but I'm just
saying like there's an different way to
do this and if you're a bone nickel spot
and it pays the same to be the greatest
favorite ever and fight guys that people
haven't heard of and they're going to
put you on TV to do it yeah I don't know
why you would rat cage yeah I think my
line to think of um is management I'm
going I'm telling Dana hey we'll fight
the duplicities we'll fight the Jared
canoners of the world we'll even
entertain the homs eye because we know
Beau wants to fight Hamza he came on
this show said he wanted to fight him
you know that day he wants to find
homzat so if I'm his management we're
both down to take those top five fights
we got to talk about the contract though
I know he has a big contract especially
for being you know just a you know a
kind of a blue chip re kind of guy you
know he doesn't have the accolades as
far as in in the Octagon but if I'm his
management going we're into this we
think we can beat these guys but we got
to do we gotta renegotiate this contract
I think Dan would be willing to play
ball they have the money
I think so too I I think that you're
completely right and I just don't know
how long we're going to do the same
thing over and over I mean I'm going
back to Izzy and Sean it looks like
we're going to redo his and Sean I'm
fine with that and I understand it but
what happens if Sean I I apologize what
happens if Izzy wins do we all then go
well the world has been right it's like
well I don't know about that Sean has
dominated him I don't know what is he
could possibly do to match that level of
domination it would still seem like
you're square and you've got to run him
back out there again yeah but the world
can't always work that way we can't just
keep on doing rematches I've never
understood the rose situation by the way
just Rose versus Joanna Johannes his big
star she's supposed to be the pros Rose
catches her knocks her out so we go to a
rematch but the rematch wasn't just
because we thought she caught her wanted
the belt around your wanna this is the
way the sport is supposed to be told and
Rose beats her again so then Rose has to
do that with somebody named Wei Lee they
fight Rose knocks her out Whaley never
touched her never pushed her grabbed her
kicked her there was nothing about that
that says rematch there was just some is
we've got our answer the better fighter
is this young lady they rematch them
it's a totally different fight but Rose
finds a way to beat her again and I'm
going to share for you like there's not
very many times when those fights go
down that the boys don't get it right
the first time like this is how we're
gonna settle this this is what we've all
agreed upon we know when we even know
the weight class they generally get it
figured out themselves the first time so
it's kind of hard to see what would be
different versus Izzy and Sean and I
don't even need to win the world over
and say Sean's a better fighter you can
think Izzy's a better fighter it could
be a match-up issue either way I don't
know how we're gonna convince the
audience that a different result is
likely to happen and I think it's a
challenge because if it does happen I
don't think they're going to the third
fight and I don't think Sean's gonna get
shown the same respect that he's showing
is he and it's just an early prediction
but I'll make that comment I'm with you
brother outside the UFC are you
following any of this Logan Paul Dylan
Dana stuff even though they're the
co-main event I mean it's hard to miss
it especially with the business we're in
um it's interesting it's interesting
because you know even you know the the
comments you made about the Nogueira
brothers or Anderson Silva we knew it
was a you know a character and it was a
very WWE of you these young kids man the
Jake Paul's of the world Dylan danis is
the ksi's the Logan Paul's dude there is
there's just no
nothing's out of limits nothing's off
limits it's just these guys just go for
blood man girlfriends fiances you know
dead dads friends it's just it's like
first rule of Fight Club be cool man be
cool you know
yeah yeah man I followed every single
bit of it I feel careful that I feel
terrible that Dylan's in a lawsuit
though I mean you know that's just a
pain in the ass that's going to take a a
little while but I mean this co-main
event has so greatly outshined the main
event I I feel like those guys maybe we
give them a little emphasis to pick up
their game I mean that that is the most
sought after boxing match going on right
now and I know how silly or amazing that
might sound to say that yeah I know
Brandon I've never heard them talk about
boxing you know oh this guy that's the
jab so I'm gonna go Southpaw I mean my
coach I've never heard them talk about
boxing yet and I'm still looking forward
to it you know the lawsuit can I tell
you a lawsuit story get a load of this
so because it would seem like Dylan
could tell Jake hey man or tell Logan
hey the gig is up you got to make her
drop this lawsuit like when we're done
boxing we are now done I I don't want
this following me around you you got to
make her do that
I was in Canada fighting with bodok Matt
lindlin who's my corner man and roommate
goes out on the town with Phil Barone
who happened to be his arch nemesis at
the time but but they go out and we're
all in one room like you remember those
days where the budgets were so low so I
know when Matt left and I know when Matt
comes back because the door makes noise
and it wakes me up and I said where have
you been because it was so late he said
I'm gonna go out for a couple hours I
said where have you been he says I've
been in jail go back to sleep it's like
you've been in jail and I'm kind of
waiting on her like I kind of want this
sleep just to escape the torture of
cutting weight he's like yeah I've been
in jail I got bailed out go back to
sleep it's like no no no no so now I'm
sitting up the lights on like okay tell
me everything well they were at some
kind of a bar and this the woman was
cleaning the tables and whenever
whenever that spray stuff she is it's
like sprayed matte so Matt like grabbed
it and like told her you know don't
don't point that at me
she calls the police for
violence battery whatever you would call
this it turns out that she is the
girlfriend of one of the top biker gang
members in town oh and this biker gang
if I could produce their name I never
did know but they were fighting a bow
dog we had like four or five of them on
a car and all their friends would come
and watch Jesus hold that thought fast
forward we're in Russia three months
later this lawsuit is still going which
means Matt is to get a legal team and go
to the country of Canada it's a total
nightmare over this misdemeanor of
spraying this chemical okay
Matt puts a Copenhagen in at lunch one
of the biker gang members says can I
have a dip and what he doesn't realize
is they don't sell loose tobacco outside
of America at least not in those
countries so we couldn't get any
Copenhagen and Matt puts it in and he
looks at how much he has left and he
tells the guy no don't have enough I'm
in the same spot as you like you're out
but I'm gonna run out I can't share it
and the guy goes I'll give you a hundred
bucks for whatever's in that can and the
guy says he goes I don't even know
what's left in the can I'll give you a
hundred for the whole can and Matt
sincerely thinks and he goes make that
lawsuit go away and you can have the cam
oh wow and the guy goes if I if I make
the lawsuit go will you give me the can
Matt slide gives him the can that guy
made one phone call and we never heard
about that lawsuit again which I think
is an amazing story but I bring it to
you because like in some regard it's
like Logan Paul you're getting points
you're getting received on this whether
Dylan went about this the way you wanted
to or not he already started he can't
stop until bedtime battle time we all
understand make that go away you got
the dispute is settled here we all walk
away clean agree 100 I don't like it
from Logan pauler's fiance it's also
Logan Paul you signed a deal with Dylan
danis this this guy he's a troll it's
what he does and I like doing that you
know I'll say it on record I'm a fan of
Dylan and it it when you made that deal
he said okay I'll take the fight but I'm
gonna sell this thing and Logan goes
please do it's more money for me goes
okay and that's what he's doing and
that's all anybody's talking about is
Dylan danis's Antics and now you want to
sue the guy
you got to know what you who you're
getting to bed with man you made a deal
with the devil and now you don't like
the way he's playing but he's selling
this thing whether I agree with it or
not which I don't but it's Dylan Dennis
you you made this deal man and now
you're in a discipline him and a lawsuit
come on I I just I don't like it I don't
like Crest board I don't like that Dylan
start going for his fiance but he
decided to do it and not only decide to
do it but it's gaining all this
attraction that's why we're talking
about the fight otherwise we're not
talking about it and then Logan doesn't
like the way he's selling the fight even
though it's kind of brilliant even
though I don't agree with it it's
brilliant it's getting millions and
millions and millions of views every
time he posts and now you're gonna
discipline the guy and lost and you got
a lawsuit I just the whole thing just
doesn't make me feel good whenever I
talk about Dylan Logan I don't feel good
about it I'll watch the fight now and
now hopefully to you know Dylan has
pulled out of several fights I think he
shows up for this one
I I would assume he shows up for this
one
it would seem like if you could get
those two guys in a room like no cameras
nobody knows what goes on I feel like
they could reason with one another where
where Logan's going to go hey man I have
a responsibility to this girl and I've
got to do everything I can to protect
her you understand and Dylan's gonna go
hey I fully get it I didn't know this
was going to work this well but Logan
make sure you understand how else was I
going to build the fight like if there's
no scenario where we talk about common
opponents or we talk about back in the
day when we were coming up through the
Junior Olympics and we sparred together
or we're at the training camp like I'm
not a boxer and you're not a boxer I'm
willing to box and you have boxed but
neither like what did you want me to
turn to except for making it personal
not to mention I only put out photos
that I found online the rest of the
world saw anyway I mean I feel as though
Logan would probably go yeah okay I mean
right you're either you're the one that
built you would hope no one goes I get
it and he's like Logan also look tell me
another route to go anytime I post your
girl it uh one of them got nine million
views dude the what does KSI doing to
sell this thing and that's your that's
your teammate that's your boy in Prime
he's not doing so this is my only
angle and to your point I think he would
go you're right my bad you're right but
you know there's just these kids are
savages man absolute Savages they have
no there's no line they won't cross and
that's what they signed up for
um before I get you out of here you
posted a video on the BTK killer now you
talk to my language I got my black belt
and serial killers I got my master's
degree in serial killers I'm Mr serial
killer talk to me chill what's BTK he's
my least favorite because he killed kids
he's my least favorite my favorite
Richard Ramirez I'm a Ted Bundy fan and
Jeffrey Dahmer fan of you know I'm not a
fan of what they did I'm sorry it comes
to these horrible people ptk is my least
favorite he's a horrible human being I
think he's he's probably the worst
serial killer we've ever had because the
way he went about it and killing kids
and making watch him kill you know their
siblings terrible person you decided to
break down BTK killer what's the video
here I haven't seen it my my team told
me to go Jail's in the serial killers
and went say what and you I think you
went with Richard Ramirez wasn't he the
Night Stalker that's the Night Stalker a
handsome guy all these women were trying
to marry him while he was on death row
by the way everyone says Ted Bundy it's
Richard Ramirez best looking serial
killer of all time the interesting thing
with BTK is when he made his confession
I mean they already had him had him and
they were going to sentence him to death
but when he goes in the judge tells him
I have to live with this decision as
much as you have to die with his
decision now I know this is written down
I know what you told the prosecutors but
I need to hear you say it let's start at
Story one tell me about the Williamson
family I'm throwing names in but he
starts at the beginning and he was
extremely candid and he spoke for an
hour and 45 minutes and he confessed
everything to your point the kids sexual
assaults after they were dead I mean
things that you wouldn't even ask of
things that are going to get you the
death penalty but he retold the story in
such a chilling way it was as though a
middle-aged man looked back at the high
school football game that he was very
proud of like BTK did this as though he
was enjoying it and it was extremely
calm and the reason that's relevant is
when he got to the end and the judge
said if we missed anything and he said
no everyone believed him like as
terrible of a guy as this was the one
thing they didn't think he was was a
liar because he was so good with the
details so all these years later the
house that he lived in at the time of
the crimes and his daughters turned on
him and she's written books you know
what it's like being his daughter and
the wife they've done their best to move
on
they go through the house that he once
lived in and I assume they've sold the
house and maybe they've sold it a couple
times that's one part of the detail that
I don't have is who had access to the
house but I I think it was somebody down
the road at any point brings you to last
week they found two trap doors
and the police as much as they'd search
it and the wife and daughter who had
lived in it nobody knew about these two
trap doors so the people called the
police the police come over they go into
the trap doors and he had left basically
a journal he confessed to other crimes
and I will I will tell you when he got
arrested I was a very young adult but I
just remember that buying torture killed
BTK and his wife would always tell him
because each was a traveling salesman he
had to leave for work all the time and
his wife would tell him how scared she
was when he was gone because we've got
this criminal around and he said he
almost said this for a comic relief he
but he said but I let her know she was
going to be just fine and that was
supposed to be like this funny one yeah
and there was something that kind of was
but I remember I remember when I heard
that 27 years ago I remember when I
heard that saying wait a minute he's a
serial killer and he's on the road
somebody should be cross-referencing
where he went up against cold case files
and up against the way those bodies were
found but that was never thought to do
because he was so candid and so open
about what he did well sure enough he
left this journal and he had taken
trophies and just by example there was a
girl that went missing in Oklahoma and
the last known photographer was taken by
her friend on something called a
Polaroid which used to be very popular
within that Polaroid she's wearing a
blue shirt that or purple rather that
purple shirt was found in one of the
crawl spaces along with a note in his
journal about killing this girl in
Oklahoma so now that we've found out he
killed at least the girl in Oklahoma how
many others are there hundreds how many
more girls did he kill and nobody really
knows they were really stunned like
Pathologists and whatnot forensics
experts were stunned to find out there
was anyone he did at Mansion because he
loved it he was so open he's done
writings on he was so open now it turns
out there's an entire
potentially Pandora's Box and that's why
he made the news and by the way he you
want to speak about the killers what
about the guy that went that went upside
down in Pennsylvania they still haven't
found that guy yeah man I I think it's
interesting with the if you're the BTK
killer you have nothing to lose man just
tell us what's going on you're never
getting out just give us the info dude
why why be secret about this especially
you know if they're trophies to them
that's what that that Gigolo Beach
killer out there that they they caught
that guy he's interested in they're
actually looking to this because he had
a lot of business in Arizona then also
outside of Seattle he had a storage unit
outside Seattle I think so he's another
guy and there's a lot of cold cases out
there they're going to start looking at
that as well so it's all weird man and
also you know when you're talking about
Richard Ramirez BTK uh Ted Bundy Dahmer
uh Ed Gaines
um uh Kemper all these guys that was
like the the Golden Age of serial
killers and they have all these cool
names and their t-shirts and
documentaries on Netflix those days are
over there's something like 60 over 65 I
think 68 serial killers active today in
North America but they don't give them
cool names anymore so so these these
guys you know become like little dick
killer or whatever they don't get like
you know Night Stalker and BTK they they
got smart about the media got smart
finally the mainstream media were like
we gotta stop giving these guys cool
names so we don't hear about them
anymore but there's there's over 60 uh
uh what's this 11 currently active
serial killers unsolved cases though
chin that's unsolved cases there's over
60 I think right now so it's interesting
you mentioned real briefly Ed Kemper but
yeah
extremely chilling they've got the
highest IQ yeah yeah that's right and
the Iceman is a very interesting one the
Iceman is what Stone Cold Steve Austin
credits for coming up with his character
of Stone Cold Steve Austin Iceman that
was just you know Stone Cold and yeah
those short man when you start going
down that rabbit hole of serial kill
it's hard to stop I used to to grow up
on a show called Unsolved Mysteries and
on Sunday nights it was called America's
Most Wanted and it was never missed but
I remember trying to sleep those nights
you know like as a little guy I remember
thinking never watch this again never
watched these shows again like they have
an effect on you oh I'm 40 dude I have
nightmares and sometimes my girl's like
stop watching and reading this crap like
I can't I can't
um Mr chalice you're the best you're the
you're the only guy I want to talk to
about the state of the middleweight
division the UFC the WWE merger the UFC
you're the best man the absolute best
you're awesome I appreciate you Brandon
have a good day brother all right
brother appreciate you